foreign
Jessica has a question for us
clutter triggers my anxiety and with
this I know that minimizing my
possessions helps me remain calm and
function better the problem that I'm
facing is that I'm a mother of two young
kids and a husband who subscribes to the
just in case mentality I understand that
it's not my job or desire to change them
but as The Keeper of the home I end up
taking the burden of tidying and
maintaining their belongings I can
handle it most days but at times I feel
resentful and frustrated what advice do
you have to help me cope with this I
don't have any advice but I have some
observations for you
you don't want to manage the Clutter you
don't want to cope with the Clutter you
want to eliminate it now you also need
to understand that what's clutter for
you may not be clutter for someone else
in the household right I was in my
daughter's room last night we were
reading some stories before bed and I I
had talked to her about clutter Core
last night as a design aesthetic and
she's like what's that I said it's when
people hold on to things that get in the
way and I'm like do you have anything in
your room right now that gets in the way
and she's like yeah this thing here and
this thing here I'm like what about that
that seems no no I use that all the time
I like playing with okay well then
that's not clutter if you enjoy it and I
have to understand that but I also
understand what is the boundary that she
has set up there when I think about
managing clutter
I think that's a problem we often try to
manage it by what organizing our clutter
you know I'm gonna do I'm going to take
a trip to Walmart or The Container Store
get a bunch of bins so I can manage my
clutter that's hiding the Clutter I'm
gonna buy more stuff to put my stuff in
it feels like the beginning of a of a
George Carlin bit right yeah it's like I
need to buy some stuff to manage my
stuff you wouldn't say that about cancer
right if you had cancer you wouldn't say
what are the best ways to manage the
cancer you say doctor how do I eliminate
this cancer I need to cut this out of my
body I can't take it this is a problem
in my life I don't want to manage my
problems I don't want to deal with my
problems I don't want to cope with my
problems I want to eliminate my problems
I want to eliminate the Clutter from my
life so I can live a more meaningful
life for me
and the only way I can do that is by
letting go and what you're telling me is
uh oh these other people in my house I'm
beginning to resent them because they
don't want exactly the same things that
I want in my life well that's going to
be true with anyone and so you have a
few Solutions here the first one is I
guess you can live by yourself if you
never want to deal with someone who has
different preferences from you
that's one thing you can do and I'm not
saying that judgmentally I'm simply
saying that's one way to deal with this
to manage the Clutter is to not bring it
in in the first place or it's to
understand
that you're letting go of needing it to
be an exact way and that's what I had to
do in my own life because Bex and Ella
have different preferences from what I
have and so I had to understand that if
I want to be able to coexist with these
other people and same with this podcast
I want to coexist with Ryan and Mallory
and TK and and the rest of our team here
well I need to let go of the expectation
that everyone is going to want exactly
what I want
I was going to say um you also have that
like your your uh personal space the
little studio apartment yes well and so
I which is but it's great though because
like you can kind of remove yourself
from uh if you're stressing out or
whatever I did this yesterday in fact
yeah um when Ella and Bex were home and
I was working from home and there was
just chaos our neighbors came over for
some reason and then that was like
friend comes over and I'm like I need to
get out if you're a media yeah and by
the way getting out of there meant going
next door or wherever or going to a
coffee shop
removing myself from the situation that
is triggering my stress response and by
the way it's not I want to be clear
about this it's not Bex and Ella that
are stressing me out I am stressing me
out based on the expectations I have of
the people in my household yeah I'm not
trying to recommend getting a studio
apartment as much as it's about removing
yourself and sometimes you do have to
take a break but I'll tell you what I
don't know if you know this or not TK
but uh Josh's nickname for me is the
messy minimalist
so I don't have a ton of stuff but
sometimes uh the little stuff I have is
everywhere and uh it's because they come
home I take off my jacket I put it on
the chair or um you know my keys are
over here my wallet's over there my
phone's over there and I remember
um you know times when Mariah came to me
and she's like hey um can you please
like you know tidy up your stuff instead
of like screwing it everywhere and I'm
like oh like because for me it doesn't
bother me to you know have a little bit
of you know um my stuff kind of
scattered throughout the place but it
bothers Mariah but she asked for help
and because I love her I want to support
her I want to I want to give to our
relationship I was like yeah no problem
like I will absolutely start looking out
for this stuff and you didn't even know
it was an issue for her until she said
something exactly so you know um yeah so
for Jessica I mean
ask for some ask for some help
um like try to you know show your
husband and show your kids like how much
it means to you to have you know a more
clutter-free Zone and I you know if you
ask for some help they might just be
willing to give it
um
I like that I like that
so man I'm thinking about this time
where me and my dad
my best friend of the world me and my
pop we were in an argument
he was concerned about some of my
choices that I was making at that time
in my life my creative risk and uh
and I said you know he said to me he
goes son
follow your dreams
but don't ask me to finance everything
that you want to do and I was like but
you're my dad you should support me and
he says okay I'm happy to support you in
whatever way I can but please don't
treat me like a bank who's obligated to
give you whatever money you ask for
without getting to have any opinions or
any say on what I think about the things
that you do you think you can just come
to me and say Hey I want to start a
business give me your money and I don't
have the right to ask you any questions
to express any curiosity about how
you're going to use that money if I'm
making the sacrifices necessary to
support you it's no longer just your
dream it's our dream and if it's our
dream I at least want to be able to get
a question in I want to at least have
something to say without feeling like
I'm the villain and I think sometimes in
life
we confuse setting boundaries with
saying no but setting boundaries isn't
just about refusing to do things that
help people sometimes setting boundaries
is about holding people accountable to
conditions that must be met in order for
them to reasonably expect the help that
we provide hey I'm okay with doing the
dishes but all the dishes have to go in
the sink and it's each person's
responsibility to make sure they put the
dishes in the sink if the dishes don't
get put in the sink they don't get done
hey I'm okay with doing the laundry but
all the laundry goes right here in this
bin anyone who wants their their clothes
wash I want them here in this bin if
it's not there it doesn't get done
sometimes we commit to doing things for
other people but we don't set any
boundaries and so now we're committed to
doing things in this unconditional
unqualified sense that treats other
people as if they're these completely
incompetent wrecks who can't be held
responsible for anything and when what
I'm hearing from you Jessica
is that you're doing all of this stuff
you say I accept the fact that I don't
want to control them and that it's not a
good thing for me to try to do so but it
always falls on me to clean up after
them to organize it and to tidy it up
and I think there's an opportunity for
you to say
I'm happy to organize things I'm happy
to tidy things but
if you're going to keep things and I
make these compromises I need some
expectation from you because in a
healthy relationship it's not just about
one party holding the other party
accountable it's about both parties
having the ability to hold one another
accountable if you're going to clean up
after them then I think they should be
able to consider you in some kind of way
if they want to hang on to these things
maybe there's an opportunity for them to
clean it up themselves or be willing to
let it go if that's not something
they're able or willing to do and maybe
that will show them that they don't love
these things as much as they want
because to love something isn't just to
want it around it's the willingness to
spend the time and energy necessary to
take care of those things did you enjoy
this Standalone patreon highlight if so
you can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube channel 100
advertisement free